some people would
define me as a steamroller my dad likes
to say that I am vivacious and I would
easily say one of the most dramatic
aspects of having cancer as an
adolescent is the separation that the
disconnection the first round of chemo
was probably the toughest because it
almost felt as if somebody had just kind
of hit the pause button in my life and
on no one else's
so everybody's life is moving really
quickly and all of a sudden everything
just stopped in mine so I was just
thinking I mean there has to be a better
way I'm Carly Rutledge and I'm a Ewing
sarcoma survivor and I live in Boulder
Colorado
that was a little bit earth-shattering I
had been accepted to the University of
Colorado my future was finally tangible
and so that was a big I really did not
want to halt my life again it had
metastasized in numerous places in her
body and we were told that the prognosis
was not good and I also knew that the
prognosis with the second line
chemotherapy was even worse than the
frontline when you are a passionate
parent you will rise up to the you know
whatever it takes so I just took it upon
myself to find out what is the latest
science and is there anything coming
available in trials for Ewing's sarcoma
specifically
can't immunotherapies goes back 30 years
and in the last 10 years
there's been some huge advances this
vaccine in particular incorporates key
mechanisms that allows you to system to
get better at now identifying the cancer
at being stronger to fight the cancer
and have being able to get them past the
walls of the cancer sets up cancer cells
starts to thrive in the body because
they are able to escape the immune
system when patient has you insert
comedies Ewing sarcoma cells they start
to grow and they start to invade
metastasize move to different places on
the surface of the cells there is some
messages to say please don't attack me
don't kill me and that's how the immune
system doesn't get activated not only
dive after they see these cancer cells
they don't go around the body say hey
listen we have something that we need to
attack these immune system police is
shut down
what we do is we take the cancer cells
for more patients then we take it to the
lab and we introduce a new message to
the genes that will stop the production
of all these messages in the surface of
the cells that tell them you system
don't get activated don't attack me so
then we prepare this vaccine and we give
it back to the patients on a monthly
basis and this time the immune system
not only see the cancer cell but get
activated start to kill the cancer cells
and also then go to the rest of the body
to tell the other cells a listen we need
to kill the cells so not only we have an
initial attack for the present tumor but
also we have a troop of cells these
police that already have a memory by the
time of new cancer cells come back new
Ewing sarcoma cells come back they are
going to kill them and it basically
retrains your immune system to be able
to fight this specific type of cancer
that has previously been able to fly
under the radar
it just made sense to make your body
more healthy so that it can fight
instead of breaking it down
just in basic principles made more sense
it's almost like your basic flu shot it
goes in your bicep and take some five to
ten seconds to get all the medicine in
and then you leave and there's no pain
other than the initial stick and there's
nausea
there's no vomiting there's no weakness
or fatigue when Carly came to us she
came with an isolated pulmonary nodule
so we did the vaccine and we saw that
month after month the same nodule stayed
at the same size it did not regress but
somehow this nodule become dormant or or
inactive and that doesn't happen in
Ewing sarcoma
it usually explodes uncontrollably and
so the fact that this little tiny nodule
in my lung refused to grow is considered
dead or calcified at this point is
momentous since 1970 and on we haven't
changed the survival of patients with
cancer so I see this vaccine and other
vaccines similar to it as opportunities
to change the survival that we have in
cancer in a significant way
our longest patient that actually
received an immunotherapy is out 21
years he was told that he should even
bother having surgery for a new brain
lesion that he had and and he's out 20
years without the cancer ever coming
back
it can happen as we learn more we're
better at creating that situation
so my freshman year it being able to be
here at school I was just kind of
reveling in the normalcy of it and just
being able to be normal and average just
going to the library with your friends
and not worrying about did everybody put
on the hand sanitizer are there gonna be
a lot of people here am I gonna get sick
if I had not chosen to do the vaccine
not only would I not have even been in
Boulder but I don't think I would have
been able to physically do these things
that I I worked really hard for a really
long time to gain my physical strength
back and at this point we just watch and
pray and hope that this vaccine
continues its work in my body and we see
clear scans for a long time from now can
we live with cancer the hope with the
vaccine was that we can first stop the
cancer from growing if in a safe way our
bodies can live with cancer and the
cancer is no longer growing it's like
diabetes it's like hypertension those
diseases aren't cured but people live a
long time with those diseases not have
any problems as long as they're taking
the medication none of us want to just
have that as our only goal and that's a
hope that in time we can build parts to
this amino therapy that'll allow us to
shrink the cancer or maybe even prevent
the cancer from coming on one day but
but this is the first step to get
control of it and live with it without
any side of it and that's what Carly's
doing right now it's your gratifying for
me to see when I can treat patients and
not have them sick and suffer while
they're getting the treatment if I'm
healthy I'm happy nothing would make me
happier than to see more people have
this treatment with no toxicity and to
see more success than they would with
the second line chemotherapy
and hopefully I can be the first to
blazed that trail and that other people
will follow me with just so much success
you
you